hey guys what is going on welcome to
another tkinter tutorial video in this
video we're gonna be doing is adding the
next two exchanges of tick data
um and then we'll start adding in the
rest of uh the information so the tick
data's kind of got to be pretty
customized whereas the rest of the
information we're going to normalize it
from cfbtc's
api so uh so now let's go ahead and add
another exchange to do that
i'm going to go ahead and just take all
this here and we'll do copy
come down here underneath bitstamp enter
enter enter
and delete once paste
and now instead of btc-e we're going to
do
uh bitfinex and biffinx also is going to
have some
changes uh does have a limit however so
we'll leave
that there uh and this
biff and x's https colon slash
slash api dot bitfinex dot
com slash v1 slash trades
uh slash bdc usd and then the variable
is
limit okay that's basically
it again uh just like before bitfinex
does not do the whole bdc usd colon
basically you specified btc usd up here
so we're just going to comment that out
we don't really need that in fact we can
just delete it there's no reason to have
it there at all
uh next uh we're going they call
uh instead of bid and ask they
use buy and sell cell
so we'll rename those now
uh we're going to come down to volume uh
like before
they do use a mount but we need to apply
float and then convert it to list
to actually use it and then again now
this is bitfinex down here
bitfinex down there and
uh they display newest to oldest as well
so that'll be the zeroth element that we
care about
and that should be it so let's go ahead
and save around that man i got itchy
neck for some reason
it's like getting really dry out here uh
i've been really itchy agree and let's
pick
uh bitfinex
okay so this is the bitfinex information
some serious volatility down here wow
back up got price volume all that
oh shoot you know what um i just
realized we
have not been uh disabling our
axes
okay so we need to add in some code here
uh so let's go ahead and scroll up uh to
the top where we have bdce
and basically right here where we're
modifying the x axis
uh if you didn't see i shouldn't have
closed it out um
we are showing basically the dates here
and here well as i said as we zoom in um
it zooms in together so there's actually
no no need uh
to show the dates twice there and as you
can see there's a little bit of overlap
that looks kind of bad
so let's go ahead and fix that really
quick um
so to do that what you do is you can say
plt.setp and then we say
a because that's the top one so we want
to remove the x-axis entirely from the
top one
or at least the labels so a dot get
underscore
x tick labels
and then empty parameters and then we're
just going to say visible equals
false and that will make them not
visible
so now when we go look at this you can
see they're just they're gone
so let's go ahead and close this and we
want to apply this
to anyone that does not have two axes so
or does have two axes rather
so bitstamp does and so does biffin x
so just apply those done
fabulous now we're going to work on
uh the huobi exchange now um
from what i know the whole exchange is a
little
uh less api friendly
i think you can get you could do the uh
the streaming like socket api i don't
really want to get into that here
so we're just going to use the data from
uh cfbtc so
um so let's just go ahead and add that
just in case the user
happens to click huobi there will be
something there for them
so we're going to say now if exchange
equals
if that is the case uh we are going to
make a plot so i'm going to copy this a
equals plt
paste but instead of row span 5 it's a
row span of
6. next our data
set is going to come from
c cfbtc so copy this and we'll come down
here
and paste and change the link here it
is http colon slash slash cfbdc.com
api api basic slash
price uh question mark
and key uh for now just put k
equals 1 that will get you through no
problem
and tf for time frame
equals uh one day and
exchange equals
and here uh what we do is
plus program
name so this is the name the lowercase
version of
wobi so that will be uh the data
that we or the data link rather
and in fact let's just do uh
data equals and then
url lib.request.url
open and then we're going to open that
bit and now let me just get to the very
end here
so plus program name close off there
period read so read the data
now if you're not too familiar the part
of the problem with reading data
off of like websites and stuff like that
in python 3
is that it's in byte code and it's not
in strings yet you want to treat it like
it's in strings so it's kind of annoying
so there's a couple of things that we
can do we can just convert it to a
string we can also do
uh like we can decode it um
so for example data equals
data dot decode and then we can print uh
print almost try to write python 2 data
or
information there print data like that
um
and we can even do string data we could
try to do something like that
so let's go ahead and save and run that
just just to see what what happens to
ourselves
uh agree exchange whoa by
will be whatever their name is
we've run we did print
yeah oh uh my shell is very angry
probably at the amount of data that
we're passing through
it's a substantial amount of data um
all of this so
okay so that's the basic data set here
and i was hoping i could scroll up a
little bit uh
but shell is angry so let's just oh no i
got rid of
everything um okay
so let's go take into a mega series here
we are on 22 let's bring that back
up my goodness
22 okay and scroll back down to animate
uh if we can find it
okay so uh the let's see if we can get
away with
uh just doing using decode here so
now we're going to say data equals
json.loads
data let's see if we can do that
agree exchange well bye hopefully no
errors
looks like we might get away with that
that's good because the old version i
was using was very hacky and i'm not
quite sure why i was doing that but
okay uh so now we've got the data loaded
in let's see if we can get away with the
rest so
date stamp is going to equal uh
np array of
uh let's see data
i have data zero in here but let's do
um well i guess i wouldn't yeah because
it's basically in two
large lists this is probably why i had
it coded the way i did
because basically what we have here is a
gigantic list of timestamps and then a
gigantic list of prices
let's see if we can do it anyway though
uh we probably can't reference let's
let's see if we can do this data zero uh
dot as type
date times 64
s not 2. then
we'll do date stamp equals
date stamp dot date
stamp oh my goodness date stamp
to list and let me
let's go ahead and do print date stamp
five okay
so run in here we go exchange
will be agree we're all happy there
uh hopefully to five would be uh
acceptable
okay so here we have uh the first five
date stamps so so far
we are still getting away uh
with what i'm hoping we're gonna get
away with
not writing horrible hacky code so
that's good now let's go ahead and we're
going to
call on pandas now so we're going to say
df data frame equals pd.data
frame and so we've got parameters here
and then curly braces
date oops
datetime colon
stamp now uh
let's see uh we're next we're gonna say
uh df price
we have price so we're assigning the a
price column here
and we're going to say that is equal to
data one
then we're saying df
volume so the volume data is
data two then
uh df
i have symbol here i'm not really sure
that symbols necessary but that's
fine uh bc usd
and then uh we're going to say we in
order to plot this stuff we have to
convert to npl dates
so we're saying dfnpl date
equals df
uh date time and then we're going to do
dot apply
and we're going to use a lambda
throwaway function here so
lambda date colon
mdates.date2num
and then in parameters here it's going
to be date.2
underscore pi date time
empty parms and then we're all set there
now we're going to say uh
df equals df.set
index so this is setting like the main
you know
column basically so set index and we're
going to set the index
to this date time column that we just
generated
um and that's that makes it really easy
to plot things with with pandas so
if you set the index as the date time
you can just basically say uh pandas
plot this stuff
and it would it would plot it we're not
going to do it that way but it's useful
to have that
and we might end up using it down the
road but anyway df
set index date time and then we're going
to go ahead and say
so we can display it we're gonna say
last price
and last price equals df
price negative one so the negative one
element and now let's go ahead and plot
this stuff so we're going to do a dot
plot underscore date
uh whoops it up plot date
uh the the date that we're gonna the
dates i suppose that we're going to plot
is df
mpl date so that's our x
uh our y is going to be df
price and then we're going to
use the light color it needs to be a
capital c
light color and then label equals
price and this is a lot of data so
we're going to go ahead and use mpl date
4500
colon and then same thing with price
minus 4500
colon um label price that's good
uh then we're going to take the same
axis locators as we have before
so that right there and so we'll go
ahead and highlight this
copy
uh let's just let's paste that
and then uh title
we'll just copy and paste this code as
well copy come down here
paste this is huobi
bdc prices last price
is actually we just used this last price
variable that we created
so we do need it to be a string still so
actually like this
so string lastprice set the title
um and that's basically it
uh so let's go ahead and save and run
that real quick
let's see how well that works if it
works
i'm still a little concerned because i
did try to get around that the original
time i programmed it
so it looks like it worked actually um
so you will at least notice
uh we don't have
uh oh
interesting i just caught that now
out with our dates uh we need to have
percent m
percent s otherwise it's treating it as
something we want to toss
in on the dates everything else looks
pretty good but percent
m percent s uh
and now we're gonna have to fix that on
everything else
so percent m percent s
percent m percent s hopefully that's the
last one nope wait one more
percent m percent s and that that should
be it okay
so um apparently we also have volume
data but
looking at the vault or this information
from c of b
c uh it looks like all zeros so
don't see any volume there and that's
interesting because we pull from huobi
um let me just see if i plot volume i
seem to recall huobi
doesn't give volume data for whatever
reason let's go to will be here
and yeah last price there's no volume
data there as opposed to like the other
uh exchanges we have last price and
volume for all of them
um so anyway yeah we don't for whatever
reason but i have like a volume thing
i might just superimpose volume there
for to normalize the data like later on
that's probably what i'm doing
uh it's been a while since i've
programmed that uh
but i'm really glad that i did not use
uh
what i in my original code i was not
decoding i was converting to string so i
was doing like
data equals string data and then to get
rid of the b
from the byte code i was doing dot
replace um
i think it was you know dot replace coin
b like that
with nothing and so we were converting
the string and then removing the the b's
from byte codes so
not the best code there i really was i'm
glad that uh decode word
i'm surprised i i don't know why i coded
that that's weird i thought like maybe
there was like some error in the way or
something that's why i still had the
code there but
i knew about decode i don't know that's
lazy code i guess
uh so anyways uh that's it we got all
the exchanges now
on tick data and that was kind of hard
just you know fitting all the exchanges
um uh so we've we've got that fixed now
hopefully that we've got all the
exchanges and then from here we're
actually going to be continuing to use
uh the c of bdc api like i said before i
haven't really no intention to charge
for like the basic pricing data
so you should be able to get by using
this basic key equals one
um at the moment i don't even think i'm
checking
for a key anyways like the only api i
have is a basic api
but down the road uh to access the api
you might need a key but i'll make sure
one always gets some sort of basic data
maybe delayed data or something like
that
but i'll make sure that hopefully this
tutorial always plays through if
anything ever changes let me know
and i'll do my best to get this back
online
uh but it shouldn't so anyway
um so that's that uh so yeah so stay
tuned to the next video
uh going to add basically all the other
time frame data so this was tick but we
all want to throw in some of the other
data sets and stuff so with this you can
kind of see how that's going to
end up but luckily it's all normalized
and i think this is why it's normalized
or
why i threw in volume here is because
the data is completely normalized across
all exchanges so you don't have to write
like custom code for who
buys so i wrote it on my website so you
don't have to ever again
so anyway uh so stay tuned for those
videos hopefully you guys enjoyed if you
guys have any questions or comments on
this
video please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support the
subscriptions
the donations and until next time